[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen an diesem zweiten advent
norbert könig ist auch dabei für den
sport
und das sind die themen von heute
koalitionsvertrag nimmt zweite hürde die
fdp stimmt mit großer mehrheit für das
regierungsbündnis mit spd und grünen
schiffbruch der zivilisation so
bezeichnet papst franziskus auf lesbos
die migrationspolitik der eu
und 14 tote tausende auf der flucht der
vulkan sie nero auf java spuckt lava und
asche
einen tag nach der spd hat jetzt auch
die fdp dem koalitionsvertrag zugestimmt
mit über 92 prozent
jetzt fehlt nur noch das jahr der grünen
das morgen kommen soll fdp chef lindner
prophezeit seine partei werde die ampel
koalition prägen aber so sein appell an
den sonderparteitag
lassen wir doch auch zu dass das
regierungshandeln uns als partei trägt
frank buchwald hat mehr
christian lindner hat es geschafft vor
vier jahren führte er die fdp zurück in
den bundestag nun geht er jeden schritt
den der 2017 noch heute nimmt er will
regieren
heute können wir sagen
es ist besser diese koalition zu vage
als auf gestaltungschancen zu verzichten
marco buschmann bald wohl justizminister
der korona politik jedoch von vielen
seiten scharf kritisiert er aber
verweist darauf freiheit und
verantwortung müssten im richtigen
verhältnis stehen verhältnismäßigkeit
bedeutet nicht dogmatisch an einmal
gefundenen ergebnissen festzuhalten
verhältnismäßigkeit bedeutet auf die
konkreten verhältnisse zu schauen auch
beim thema impfpflicht bewegt sich die
fdp einen entsprechenden antrag
verschiebt der virtuelle parteitag zwar
nach weihnachten aber soll eine experten
anhören sich damit beschäftigen die
angehende bildungsministerin bettina
stark watzinger setzt vor allem auf eine
neue sozialpolitik
mit dem koalitionsvertrag schaffen wir
den einstieg in eine reform unserer
sozialsysteme weg vom reparaturbetrieb
hin zum chancengeber in unserer
gesellschaft die fdp übt einen neuen ton
linda weniger angriffslustig hier betont
die unabhängigkeit der liberal ein
linksruck sei das aber nicht es ist ein
koalitionsvertrag für eine politik der
mitte der unser land nicht nach links
rückt sondern nach vorne führen will
immerhin das finanzministerium haben die
liberalen erobert steuern werden nicht
erhöht die schuldenbremse bleibt ernste
prüfung und für das liberale gewissen
aber werden schon noch kommen
verkehrsminister für die fdp soll volker
wissing werden er ruft dazu auf wegen
der aktuellen corona situation über die
feiertage keine größeren reisen durchs
land zu planen es sei sinnvoller
weihnachten im kleinen kreis zu hause zu
verbringen sagte er der bild am sonntag
csu-landesgruppenchef dobrindt reagierte
prompt es verwundere ihn wenn wissing
als kritiker der bisherigen coroner
regeln jetzt offenbar an
reisebeschränkungen denke die omikron
variante des corona virus macht weiter
sorgen in dänemark hat sich die zahl der
bestätigten fälle innerhalb von 48
stunden verdreifacht auf jetzt über 180
hierzulande gibt es bislang vier
bestätigte fälle die aktuellen
gesamtzahlen sehen so aus das robert
koch institut meldet
42.000 55 neuinfektionen binnen 24
stunden
2346 weniger als vor einer woche
94 todesfälle kamen dazu die sieben tage
incidents sinkt leicht auf 4
139,2
mit drastischen worten hat der papst
europas umgang mit flüchtlingen
angeprangert auf seiner
griechenlandreise sprach franziskus von
einer epoche der mauern und des
stacheldrahts die das mittelmeer zu
einem kalten friedhof ohne grabsteine
mache in einem flüchtlingslager auf der
insel lesbos sprach er den migranten mut
zu annette helfen weg
sie sind überwältigt wie nah er innen
ist papst franziskus nimmt sich im
flüchtlingslager auf lesbos viel zeit
für die menschen und gibt jenen
zuneigung die gekommen sind voller
hoffnung dass er ihnen hilft
ich heute gerne unsere schwierige lage
mit ihm reden erst her gekommen und kann
vieles für uns verändern
es ist ein besuch des trostes und der
kritik in europa gebe es immer noch
menschen die so täten als ob die
situation auf den griechischen inseln
sie nichts angehe so der papst
lasst uns die lähmende angst überwinden
die todbringende gleichgültigkeit das
zynische desinteresse das sind samt
haben schon die zum tode verurteilt die
am rande stehen
lassen wir nicht zu dass das mittelmeer
sich in ein trostloses mehr der toten
verwandelt ich bitte euch lasst uns
diesen schiffbruch der zivilisation
stoppen
da schon zuvor hatte papst franziskus
angekündigt 50 flüchtlinge aus zypern
aufzunehmen hat damit bereits ein
deutliches signal an die eu staaten
gesetzt auf seiner apostolischen reise
nach zypern und griechenland hat pabst
franziskus sind zum teil drastischen
worten das schicksal der migranten
beklagt hier auf lesbos ermahnt europa
zu gemeinsamen zu menschenwürdigen
umgang mit den migranten die not der
menschen die übers mittelmeer kommen
dürften weder mit stacheldraht noch mit
gleichgültigkeit beantwortet werden
immer mehr bewohner von pflegeheimen
sind auf sozialhilfe angewiesen ihre
zahl stieg vergangenes jahr um gut fünf
prozent auf fast
337.000 das berichtet das redaktions
netzwerk deutschland und beruft sich auf
das statistische bundesamt wichtigste
ursache die eigenanteile in den
pflegeheimen seien deutlich gestiegen
während viele gebannt verfolgen wie es
mit dem vulkan auf la palma weitergeht
bringt ein anderer ausbruch in
indonesien tod und zerstörung
mindestens 14 menschen kamen ums leben
rund ein dutzend dörfer hat es getroffen
der vulkan semedo erhebt sich im osten
der insel java in der gegend kommt es
oft zu erdbeben und vulkanausbrüchen
weil sie auf dem so genannten
pazifischen feuergürtel liegt alexandra
vacano berichtet
wo man auch hinsieht überall dicker
schlamm der so viel unter sich begraben
hat erst die asche die der vulkan semedo
gestern ausgespuckt hat dann kam der
starke regen dazu jetzt graben
rettungskräfte mit bloßen händen nach
weiteren opfern viele sind verletzt
haben brandwunden oder atemprobleme
zerstört in dieser katastrophe auch das
hab und gut der menschen mehr als 1000
können vorerst nicht in ihre häuser
zurück so der nationale
katastrophenschutz in dieser
notunterkunft haben rund 350 kinder
frauen und männer zuflucht gefunden
beim ausbruch war es so dunkel was
wichtig ist dass meine familie in
sicherheit ist aber viele meiner
nachbarn starten ich bin so dankbar und
natürlich hatte ich angst als der vulkan
ausbrach
simyo verdunkelte mit seiner kilometer
hohe rauchwolke den himmel fühlte
dutzende dörfer auf der insel java in
asche tausende mussten fliegen
jeder hatte angst und rannte in panik
davon dieser ausbruch war sehr viel
größer als der im letzten jahr
eingestürzte brücken die dicke
schlammschicht und immer noch heiße
aschewolken sie erschweren die arbeit
der retter auf der insel java
jetzt fußball norbert die dritte
trainerentlassung dieser saison rb
leipzig hat sich von jesse marsch
getrennt das heißt dass sowohl der
trainer wie auch geschäftsführer oliver
mintzlaff den glauben an einen erfolg
der zusammenarbeit beim
meisterschaftszweiten der vergangenen
saison verloren hätten der us-amerikaner
marsch hatte erst im sommer den job von
julian nagelsmann übernommen leipzig ist
aktuell elfter in der liga und hat die k
der champions league verpasst
der dfb kontrollausschuss ermittelt
gegen dortmund süd bellingham der 18
jährige hatte nach dem 2 3 gegen bayern
münchen die nominierung des
schiedsrichters felix zweier kritisiert
dieser habe schon spiele manipuliert
meinte der engländer in anspielung auf
den wettskandal um robert hoyzer 2004
im ersten bundesliga sonntagsspiel holt
hertha bsc in stuttgart beim debüt von
trainer tayfun korkut ein 2 2 nach 0 2
rückstand und skisprung weltmeister karl
geiger baut mit platz vier in rees war
seine führung im gesamtweltcup aus
markus eisenbichler wird fünfter beim
erfolg des österreichers jahnhöhe
deutsche siege gab es meist kanal
58 zur weltcup sieg für francesco
friedrich auf seiner heimbahn in
altenberg triumphiert er heute im vierer
mit den anschiebern markus baur und
schüler der weltmeister und
olympiasieger besiegt mit zwei nahezu
perfekten fahrten das quartett aus
österreich im zweierbob der frauen hat
es erstmals in diesem winter nicht ganz
gereicht laura nolte und deborah lee wie
landen vier hundertstel hinter den
amerikanerinnen humphries und lars dafür
erster weltcupsieg für julia taubitz die
rodlerin verteidigt auf der olympia bahn
in sotschi ihre führung aus dem ersten
lauf und gewinnt mit mehr als drei
zehntel sekunden vor teamkollegin
natalie geisenberger die olympiasiegerin
steht erstmals in dieser saison auf dem
podium
noch ein zwischenstand aus der
bundesliga mönchengladbach 0 freiburg
610 mit unverschlossen wird die
freiburger freund
fehlt noch das wetter an der ostsee in
sachsen und am alpenrand etwas schnee
oder schneeregen sonst meist trocken und
gelegentlich auch sonne höchstwerte
minus ein bis plus fünf grad im heute
journal um viertel vor zehn spricht
christian sievers mit fdp chef christian
lindner hier übernimmt morgen mitri
sirin wir sagen tschüss wünschen ihnen
alles gute einen fröhlichen start in die
neue woche